first on CBS this morning a report
released overnight says fake check scams
are becoming more widespread the Better
Business Bureau study finds billions of
dollars of fake checks circulate every
year scammers fool their victims using
checks that appear to come from real
companies the scam is called an
exploding epidemic
I'm Tony de copal is here to show us how
it works Tony good morning good morning
tens of thousands of people fall victim
to these scams every year here's how
they work scammers will send consumers a
fake check and then ask them to send
some money to account set up for fake
business purposes but the checks often
bounce back days later we spoke to one
victim who was looking for extra work to
help pay her college tuition they were
offering me money to have me represent
pepsico college student ariane jacobs
from oakland california said scammers
sent her an email in March appearing to
be from another student they offered her
two hundred and fifty dollars a week to
have an advertisement for Mountain Dew
wrapped around her car all I have to do
is just drive my car around and just
live my normal life while advertising
for them she sent in her application and
received a nearly five thousand dollar
check with instructions to deposit it in
her bank account
she then withdrew three thousand five
hundred and deposited it in the alleged
scammers account to cover the
installation of the advertisement soon
after Jacobs Bank alerted her that the
check was fake
and she owed the bank that three
thousand five hundred dollars that she
withdrew I was actually really counting
on that to pay a huge portion of my
tuition
Steve Baker is an investigator with the
Better Business Bureaus we think there
may be half a million victims in the
United States of this every year in a
new report the Better Business Bureau
warns that regular checks cashier's
checks and money orders can all be
forged
they found fake cheque fraud and reports
about employment frauds sweepstake
frauds and smaller numbers in areas such
as bogus grants tech support online
purchase fraud and rental frauds what
they all have in common is that the
check is counterfeit and just because
the money is credited to your account
does not mean the check is good the FTC
and FBI received nearly 30,000
complaints about check fraud last year
combined
reported total losses of nearly 40
million dollars people in their 20s
accounted for 21% of FTC complaints in
the last two years the Postal Inspection
Service said it sees sixty two billion
dollars in fake checks in 2017 alone if
you get a check from somebody who is not
a family member or in person or it's not
a payroll check you need to wait at
least two weeks to be sure that that
check really is goodness not counterfeit
now Jacobson college student says she
paid back that $3500 with help from her
parents the Better Business Bureau said
these scams seem to originate from
Nigeria there are large and organized
networks there and they can they say
consumers should do their research and
try to independently verify any
information provided by anybody
particularly online the report is called
don't cash that check but here's the
thing if you do catch it the bank will
put it in your account doesn't mean the
check is good don't start withdrawing it
anytime soon yeah wait till it's cleared
indeed reminds me of that catch me if
you can yes it's a movie with an order
of the carryover he had those all those
except that ones fun and games